Así es hablamos de la noticia del día
este viernes se dio a conocer en la
capital francesa el recorrido de la
llama olímpica que llegará al territorio
francés el 8 de mayo del próximo año y
culminará el 26 de julio con la
ceremonia inaugural de estas justas el
anuncio se hizo en la universidad de la
sorbona en donde se encuentra nuestra
compañera Natalia Ruiz giraldo Natalia
allá allá olímpica estará por toda
Francia continental también en los
territorios de ultramar cuáles son los
detalles de este recorrido
Muy buenas tardes pues muchísimos
detalles dieron hoy de este recorrido
inmenso doce mil kilómetros en total de
olímpica que primero Pues será encendida
como es tradición en Olimpia esto es en
Grecia eso será el 16 de abril de la
próximo año y luego llegará a través del
Mediterráneo a bordo de El Belén barco
francés de tres masiles hasta Marsella
el ocho de mayo Y a partir de ese
momento pues comienzan más de 60 días de
recorrido por lo por todo el territorio
francés no solamente continental sino
también en los territorios de ultramar
va a pasar por al menos 100 lugares
digamos emblemáticos de la cultura
francesa que sea el Palacio de Versalles
el monte bondú por donde siempre pasa el
Tour de Francia por ejemplo el monte San
Miguel también la estación espacial de
curu esto es en la Guyana Francesa ahí
en en Sudamérica y tendrá cosas muy
interesantes por ejemplo precisamente
para ir a las antillas pues lo hará a
bordo de el maxi
es uno de los Navegantes más conocidos
de Francia que siempre hace estas
vueltas al mundo en el solitario a bordo
de esta de de esta de este barco y pues
era él el encargado de llevarla allí y
luego regresará Esto será el siete de
junio y luego regresará a Francia para
un día muy especial será aquí a París el
14 de Julio es el día de la fiesta
nacional y luego bueno continuará este
recorrido hasta el 26 de julio que será
la ceremonia inaugural también aquí en
la capital francesa mucho simbolismo
como no este tipo de eventos que podemos
decir ahora acerca de los portadores de
esta llama Olímpica
Bueno pues lo interesante también de
este recorrido y en lo que hicieron
énfasis hoy cuando Tony el presidente
Pues de este comité organización hizo
esta presentación pues era también poner
digamos por delante todo lo que es la
gastronomía la cultura francesa y pues
para esto hay cuatro capitanes que van a
participar en este relevo se trata de
cuatro deportistas dos atletas dos para
atletas dos de ellos pues son los ya
medallistas Olímpicos y su hermano flojo
manudú ellos ganaron medallas en
anteriores Juegos Olímpicos en natación
y también Pues habrá otras
personalidades ahora estarás tierra y
Mac tierra y Max que es un chef francés
muy conocido e incluso El astronauta
toma pesqué También él estará pues
formará parte de todo este relevo son
más de diez mil personas las que van a
relevarse esta llama olímpica a través
de más de 12.000 kilómetros que van a
recorrerse a lo largo de de todos esos
días esta noticia se ha recorrido
Natalia no ha estado exento de críticas
algunos se quejan del valor de este
recorrido por qué
bueno porque en realidad pues decía que
tenía unos costos bastante prohibitivos
hoy hablamos con el presidente de las
regiones de Francia donde sea bueno hubo
varias ciudades que de hecho lo que
hicieron fue asociarse para poder
mantener este costo que está por encima
de los 180.000 euros además de esto O
sea les decía hay cuatrocientas ciudades
pero también hay 65 ciudades digamos
etapa es decir que allí va a haber
Digamos como un como una una parada de
esa llama olímpica con toda una cantidad
de conciertos y demás que son Pues los
sponsors los que van a estar allí pues
con este gran evento entonces por eso
pues había mucha polémica respecto a
esto por el costo que podía tener como
les decía acerca de los 200.000 euros y
por eso hubo varias ciudades algunas que
dijeron No que no podemos pagar esto y
otros que finalmente decidieron pues
justamente aunar esfuerzos para poder
tener esta llama olímpica es importante
también para muchas regiones de tener
esa visibilidad porque esto es algo pues
que va a seguir el mundo entero
Natalia Muchísimas gracias Seguiremos
atentos toda la antesala de estos juegos
olímpicos que se inauguran este próximo
26 de julio 2024 Valentina toma pesque
uno de los portadores de la llama un
viejo conocido de esta casa con esa
misión especial a la que le hicimos
seguimiento